aujourd'hui il ya des variantes de
variants de variants parce qu'on
n'arrête pas de faire de la pédagogie
avec des gens qui ne veulent rien
entendre 87% défense ont fait le choix
de vacciner eh bien demain moi je vous
le dire le fond de ma pensée c'est qu'au
fond il a fait le choix d'être libre de
son corps ici et bien confie non celles
et ceux qui ont fait un choix vous êtes
comme comme l'autriche il faut faire il
faut confirmer qu aux lésions de
dictature salle et on vaccine pourquoi
la punition collective
doit-elle revenir au nom de quoi celles
et ceux qui ont fait le choix de se
vacciner de vivre d'être joyeux tout
simplement parce qu'au fond ce sont des
gens très bonne histoire qu'on comprenne
et nous avons fait le choix de vivre
juste vivre la vraie la liberté stéphane
juste pour qu'on comprenne vous vouliez
vous vous dites allons au bout et on ne
confine les non vaccinés non j'avais dit
qu'on confine on met des restrictions à
partir de 21h un couvre-feu moi je ne
souhaite pas que demain puisque c'est ce
qui devrait en tout cas c'est sur la
table je souhaite pas que la punition
collective reviennent 87% des français
et des françaises ont fait un autre
jouet pour l'essayer à réaliser chez
vous ils répondent aux formes éteignons
va continuer 87 % des français ont fait
le choix de se vacciner je vous rappelle
que je suis pour la liberté vaccinale et
je ne suis pas si je suis pas un anti
works a maintenant parce que vous avez
c'est d'instrumentaliser quand même les
choses 87 % des français sont vaccinés
tous les jours cinquante mille
contaminés on est d'accord là dessus a
fait les chiffres d'aujourd'hui c'est
bien les chiffres qu'on a aujourd'hui
50 mille contaminé jours ci des vaccinés
qui peuvent attraper le virus et oui
donné le virus et faire des formes
grande accord est génial mais c'est
attendre a continué de la norme je vous
ai laissé finir on va finir des des
hôpitaux on est en train de re déclenché
les plans blancs vous savez qui est en
réanimation aujourd'hui est ce que vous
savez qui est la majorité des personnes
qui sont en réanimation aujourd'hui
motive non vaccinés lovenox
annoncé en fanfare les infos sur sa vie
qu'on voulait non c'est pas cette vérité
n'est fini ce matin si vous voulez je
vous le saurez vous le voulez il serait
à la déraison séisme atteint lci ce
matin on nous dit que la tendance est en
train de s'inverser
il serait temps que les médias philippe
gilbert dorel services bénévoles tout le
monde évoque 6 mais tout le monde est en
train de dire à 87% de la population
coquet ille la vérité à travers des
spots publicitaires
vous leur avez dit allez vous vacciner
pour vous protéger pour pu faire de
formes graves et ces gens n'ont même pas
d olive olive on imagine alors la
version finale non juste une seule nuit
en transit mais a justifié je vais vous
dire quelque chose on fait quoi et c'est
triste et c'est triste mais en train
vacciner non vaccinés le non vaccinés
je vais vous dire me voir pour les fans
est passé cette année c'est
quelqu'un qui évoque signer aujourd'hui
ne se tait ce n'est pas elle peut
transmettre le virus elle peut
contaminer les volumes je suis chez
asuka moyano oliva nul au niveau libre
juste une chose ça veut dire que vous
vous avez en démarrer en préambule
disant je ne suis pas anti vaccins mais
là vous allez dire que bastien ne sert à
rien je dis pas qui sert à rien je dis
absolument pas ça je dis juste que
aujourd'hui on annoncé pendant des mois
et des mois que ce vaccin protège à 95%
on voit aujourd'hui c'est complètement
faux
on